Okay, so now we have some idea of what
is privacy in the online context.
What kind of information is private and
what may not be private.
Let's talk about some
threats to privacy.
Well on the internet, we talk about
a source of a request that goes to
a certain service or a destination, and
so we communicate between two endpoints.
Analysis of who's talking to who.
Obviously, think that who I
communicate with should be private.
Of course this traffic
analysis is a threat to that.
It can violate, or
disclose that information.
Other threat to privacy is,
of course, large scale surveillance.
And recently, in fact this month,
this letter from this encryption
experts was published about
the law enforcement agency's
claim that if we allow encryption
without, sort of, some way to undo it,
or backdoors and things like that,
then it's like going dark.
Their ability to see what bad guys
are doing completely going away.
So, the other people who
are arguing against that by saying,
this is sort of the golden
age of surveillance.
The amount of information they
can collect is unprecedented.
So, in some sense, everything you do
online potentially can be tracked and
collected, information about your
activities can be collected.
So if somebody is doing that, of course,
that's a massive threat to privacy.
Finally, with big data, data mining
analytics that we have, we can do all
kind of inferences and link different
pieces of information, okay.
When we talked about
database of privacy,
we did discuss inference attacks and
anonymization and things like that.
Well, those could be defeated and
we have, by linking different pieces of
information, very simple
online advertising.
They're sort of making a guess
that you visit certain websites or
click on certain kind of links,
you'll be interested in certain things.